>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IN JANUARY OF 2000, BILL CLINTON
GAVE HIS FINAL STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS TO CONGRESS.
CLINTON USED THAT SPEECH TO PUSH
FOR DROPPING TRADE BARRIERS
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
HERE IS THE ARGUMENT HE MADE.
ALLOWING CHINA INTO THE WORLD
TRADE ORGANIZATION, CLINTON
PROMISED AMERICA, WOULD "OPEN
CHINA'S MARKETS TO THE
UNITED STATES" AND "PLAINLY
ADVANCE THE CAUSE OF PEACE IN
ASIA AND THE CAUSE OF CHANGE IN
CHINA."
IN HIS LAST YEAR IN OFFICE,
CLINTON MADE EXPANDING THE
CHINESE ECONOMY ONE OF HIS MOST
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES.
TO DO THAT HE APPOINTED A
LOBBYIST CALLED STEVE MACHETE
AND PUT HIM IN CHARGE OF THE
PROJECT.
FAST FORWARD TO TODAY, CHINA HAS
BEEN A MEMBER OF THE WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION FOR 20 YEARS.
STEVE HAS WRITTEN AN EVEN HIGHER
IN DEMOCRATIC POLITICS AND
IS A TOP WHITE HOUSE AIDE TO
JOE BIDEN.
AS FOR CHINA, IT HAS CHANGED AS
BILL CLINTON PROMISED IT WOULD.
CHINA IS NOW THE RICHEST COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD, POLICE STATE IS
FAR MORE EFFICIENT
AUTHORITARIAN EVEN THEN IT WAS
UNDER CHAIRMAN MAO.
CHINA IS A MUCH LARGER THREAT IN
UNITED STATES AND ITS NEIGHBORS,
AS FAR FROM PEACE IN ASIA AS WE
HAVE BEEN SINCE 1945.
THE AMERICAN MANUFACTURING
SECTOR IS GONE, EVAPORATED, MOST
PRODUCTS ARE MADE IN CHINA
THEATER MAYBE YOU SEEN THE
PICTURES OF CARGO SHIPS STRUNG
OUT INTO THE PACIFIC, STRUGGLING
TO GET TO A PORT TO UNLOAD
CONTAINERS.
YOU WILL HEAR THIS DESCRIBED AS
PART OF THE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN,
BUT THAT INTENTIONALLY
UNDERSTATE WHAT IS ACTUALLY IS.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT OUR
AMERICA'S SUPPLY LINES.
AT THIS POINT WE ARE EFFECTIVELY
TOTALLY DEPENDENT ON A FARAWAY
HEADQUARTER FOR THE THINGS WE
NEED TO LIVE.
HERE'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> WHY SO MANY EMPTY SHELVES?
U.S. PORTS ARE BACKED UP.
>> TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
CARGO SHIPS SITTING IN THE SEA
WAITING TO PULL INTO PORT.
IT IS CAUSING MAJOR U.S.
RETAILERS LIKE WALMART,
HOME DEPOT, AND COSTCO, TO TURN
TO A PRIVATE CARGO SHIPS IN A
RUSH TO FILL SHELVES FOR THE
HOLIDAY SEASON.
ON THE ROAD, THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OF TRUCK DRIVERS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS IT IS
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES FUELED BY
COVID-19, A LABOR SHORTAGE, AND
INCREASED DEMAND.
>> Tucker: SUDDENLY, FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN GENERATIONS,
AMERICANS ARE HAVING TROUBLE
BUYING BASIC NECESSITIES, THINGS
THEY NEED.
A NEW POLL BY RASMUSSEN FOUND
62% OF AMERICANS SAID THEY HAD
SHORTAGES IN STORES WHERE THEY
LIVE.
THE THINGS THEY CAN BUY ARE
SUDDENLY MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
>> THE LABOR DEPARTMENT
REPORTING WEDNESDAY, MEATS,
POULTRY, FISH, EGGS INCREASED A
COMBINED 10.5% SINCE SEPTEMBER
OF 2020.
BUT IT IS NOT JUST FOOD PRICES
SKYROCKETING, THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX SHOWS UP, UP 5.4% FOR A
YEAR AGO.
MORE PAYING AT THE PUMP, NATURAL
GAS PRICE ROSE $1 SINCE LAST
YEAR, AAA SHOWING THE AVERAGE
PRICE PER GALLON UP FROM $2.18
IN 2020, TO $3.29 THIS YEAR.
THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION SAYS INFLATION IS
WHY NEARLY 70 MILLION AMERICANS
RECEIVING SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS WILL SEE A NEARLY 6%
INCREASE IN PAYMENTS NEXT YEAR.
THE HIGHEST INCREASE IN FOUR
DECADES.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE NO SIGNS
THAT FUNDAMENTALLY ANY OF THIS
IS GOING TO IMPROVE ANY TIME
SOON.
IN FACT, ON WEDNESDAY, THE
ADMINISTRATION ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
YOUR HEATING BILLS ARE LIKELY TO
JUMP BY MORE THAN 50% THIS
WINTER.
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
PEOPLE ACTUALLY NOTICE.
IT HURTS WHEN YOU GET POORER,
AND MANY PEOPLE ARE GETTING
POORER.
BUT STRANGELY, THE MINISTRY SHE
HAS REFUSED TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
LET ANYTHING, THEY ARE
SALIVATING AT.
LAST NIGHT, A HARVARD PROFESSOR
CALLED JASON FURMAN, CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH THE WHAT BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE, SENT THIS TWEET,
"MOST OF THE ECONOMIC PROBLEMS
WE ARE FACING FROM INFLATION,
SUPPLY CHAINS, ET CETERA, ARE
HIGH-CLASS PROBLEMS.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THEM IF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WAS STILL
10%."
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU OUGHT TO BE
THRILLED TO HAVE LESS MONEY, IT
MEANS WE ARE WINNING.
RON KLAIN, JOE BIDEN'S CHIEF OF
STAFF AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
PROMPTLY ENDORSED THAT TWEET.
AND THAT IS DELUSION.
OR MAYBE IT IS INTENTIONAL.
YOU PRETEND YOUR FAILURES ARE
VICTORIES AND SOME PEOPLE WILL
DOUBTLESS BELIEVE YOU.
THAT SEEMS TO WORK IN
AFGHANISTAN, MAYBE IT WILL WORK
HERE.
THAT COULD BE THERE THINKING.
BUT IT WON'T HEAR WORK HERE BECE
DOMESTIC POLICY IS NOT THE SAME
AS --
PEOPLE NOTICE WHEN YOU CANNOT
BUY PRESENTS FOR YOUR CHILDREN
OR KEEP YOUR HOUSE WARM IN
JANUARY.
THESE ARE NOT SYMBOLIC PROBLEMS,
THESE ARE MEASURABLE DECLINES IN
YOUR FAMILY STANDARD OF LIVING
AND THEY HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
IF ECONOMIC DECLINE CONTINUES
AND IT SEEMS LIKELY TO CONTINUE,
YOU WILL SEE A PROFOUND
POLITICAL RESET IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND HERE IS WHY.
THE ONLY REASON AMERICANS HAVE
PUT UP WITH THE ENDLESS AWOKE
GARBAGE THE LEFT TURNS OUT BY
THE GALLON IS BECAUSE THEY CAN
AFFORD TO PUT UP WITH AT.
FOR GENERATIONS, THIS HAS BEEN A
VERY RICH COUNTRY AND AFFLUENCE
COVERS A MULTITUDE OF SIN.
PEOPLE WILL TOLERATE A LOT OF
THINGS THEY DISAGREE WITH, AS
LONG AS GAS IS CHEAP AND AMAZON
DELIVERIES KEEP COMING.
BUT WHEN A SOCIETY BECOMES POOR
RARE, PEOPLE'S ATTITUDES CHANGE,
AND THEY CHANGE FAST.
FOR ONE THING, THEY BECOME MUCH
LESS PATIENT WHEN THEY ARE
MISTREATED.
YOU ARE FIRING ME RIGHT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS BECAUSE I WON'T TAKE
YOUR SHOT?
NO, I'M RESISTING THAT.
YOU ARE TELLING ME MY SON CAN'T
GET A JOB BECAUSE HE IS THE
WRONG SCHOOL SKIN COLOR?
THAT'S WRONG AND I'M GOING TO
FIGHT IT.
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
POLITICS WILL LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT IN A COMPANY WITH
PERMANENT SHORTAGES.
AND THIS MAY BE AN UNPLEASANT
SURPRISE FOR THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THE PROGRESSIVE LEFT'S ENTIRE
PROGRAM IS BUILT ON THE
PRESUMPTION OF ENDLESS,
BOUNDLESS AFFLUENCE.
OF COURSE WE CAN AFFORD THAT, WE
ARE RICH.
PEOPLE LIKE NANCY PELOSI AND
SANDY CORTEZ AND RASHIDA TLAIB
BELIEVE THAT.
THEY BELIEVE IT AS A MATTER OF
FAITH.
THEY TALK ABOUT ECONOMICS, BUT
THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW THE ACTUAL
ECONOMY WORKS.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THE GREAT AMERICAN AFFLUENCE
MACHINE.
THEY NEVER REALLY HAD JOBS.
THE ONE THING THEY KNOW FOR
CERTAIN, DEAD CERTAIN, IS THAT
EVERY GOOD THING MUST BE FREE,
IT HAS TO BE.
BUT THAT IS NOT HOW LIFE WORKS.
CERTAINLY NOT IN COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T HOLD THE WORLD RESERVE
CURRENCY.
THERE IS A REASON THEY DON'T
HAVE DRAG QUEEN STORY HOUR IN
MEXICO.
PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT -- THEY
DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THAT
KIND OF NONSENSE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO BECOME A LOT
MORE LIKE MEXICO.
IT TURNS OUT OUR ECONOMY WAS
MUCH MORE FRAGILE THAN WE
THOUGHT IT WAS.
IF WE HAD KNOWN THAT EARLIER, WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE ELECTED AN
ECONOMIC ILLITERATE LIKE
JOE BIDEN AS PRESIDENT.
HERE IS JOE BIDEN DURING THE
CAMPAIGN ITS PLAINTIVE CNN
ANCHORS THAT ACTUALLY, PRINTING
TRILLIONS OF NEW DOLLARS FOR
WASTEFUL GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST
PROGRAMS WILL REDUCE INFLATION.
>> PUMPING ALL OF THIS MONEY
INTO THE ECONOMY, COULDN'T THAT
ADD TO --
>> LOOK, HERE IS THE DEAL.
WALL STREET FIRM, NOT SOME
LIBERAL THINK TANK, SAID IF WE
PASS THE OTHER TWO THINGS I'M
TRYING TO GET DONE, WE WILL IN
FACT REDUCE INFLATION, REDUCE
INFLATION, REDUCE INFLATION.
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING GOOD OPPORTUNITIES AND
JOBS FOR PEOPLE WHO, IN FACT,
ARE GOING TO BE REINVESTING THAT
MONEY BACK INTO ALL THE THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: DID I SAY THE
CAMPAIGN?
HE WAS ACTUALLY PRESENT WHEN HE
SAID THAT.
THAT WAS THIS JUNE, WHEN HE
STOOD ON STAGE, LOOKED UNDER THE
CAMERA AND TOLD US WHEN YOU MAKE
MORE MONEY AND PRINT MORE U.S.
DOLLARS, THE VALUE OF U.S.
DOLLARS GOES UP.
THEN YOU WATCH THE CNN ANCHORS
NOT LIKE LIVESTOCK.
IT MADE SENSE TO THEM.
BUT OF COURSE IT IS LUDICROUS.
IS JUST ABOUT EVERY SANE PERSON
HAS ACKNOWLEDGE SINCE, INFLATION
IS RISING, THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
HASN'T DEVALUED THE U.S. DOLLARS
BY MAKING TOO MANY, THEY ARE NOT
WORTH MUCH.
BUT STILL, THE WHITE HOUSE DOES
NOT SEEM CONCERNED.
PETE BUTTIGIEG HAS BEEN ON LEAVE
FROM HIS JOB SINCE AUGUST AFTER
ADOPTING A CHILD, PATERNITY
LEAVE, THEY CALL IT, TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BREASTFEED, I
WONDER HOW THAT WENT.
NOW HE IS BACK IN OFFICE AT AS
THE TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY AND
HE IS DEEPLY AMUSED, HE SAID, TO
SEE DOZENS OF CONTAINER SHIPS
CAN'T MAKE IT INTO THIS COUNTRY.
>> AS WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES, HOW BAD ARE
THEY GOING TO GET FOUR
AMERICANS, AND I'M TALKING
SPECIFICALLY, YOU KNOW, LEADING
HERE INTO THE DECEMBER HOLIDAYS,
WHERE PEOPLE ARE RELYING ON
GETTING GOODS, ON GETTING
PRESENTS.
>> I THINK THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TWO KINDS OF CHRISTMAS SHOPPERS.
THERE IS THE ONE SO HAVE ALL
THEIR LISTS COMPLETED BY
HALLOWEEN, AND THEN THERE'S
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO SHOW UP AT
THE MALL ON CHRISTMAS EVE.
IF YOU ARE IN THAT LATTER
BUCKET, OBVIOUSLY THERE IS GOING
TO BE MORE CHALLENGES.
>> Tucker: KIND OF A FUNNY
LITTLE DORKY DAD STORY, I WAIT
UNTIL THE LAST MINUTE TO SHOP
FOR CHRISTMAS.
THAT IS NOT THE POINT, PETE DO
BUTTIGIEG, YOU ARE THE
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY AND
OUR -- IS BROKEN.
IS NOT A PROBLEM?
NO, IT IS AMUSING.
THE DEEPER TRUTH IS PEOPLE CAN
GET GOODS, OUR LEADERS OUTSOURCE
PRODUCTION TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
AND THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE IT
IS A GOOD THING.
THEY WANT YOU SO BADLY TO
BELIEVE IT IS A GOOD THING,
THEIR ALLIES IN THE MEDIA ARE
REPEATING THAT MESSAGE VERBATIM.
>> I TALKED LAST NIGHT, HE
EXPLAINED TO ME ABOUT THE SUPPLY
CHAINS, IT IS A TERRIBLE AND
PEOPLE WANT TO GET THEIR THINGS
BUT IT IS ALSO AN INDICATOR THE
ECONOMY IS DOING WELL.
PEOPLE WANT TO BUY THINGS, AND
IT IS BACKED UP.
LET'S LOOK AT THE PARK, HATE,
THE ECONOMY IS GREAT AND PEOPLE
CAN BUY THINGS, THEY ARE OUT AND
ABOUT AND WANT TO BUY --
I THINK IT IS A LITTLE SPINNING.
>> IT IS SPINNING FROM
UNDERSTRENGTH TO MAKE PEOPLE
FEEL GOOD.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT MAKING
THE CASE FOR CREDENTIALS OR
EXPERTISE.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE TEACHES AT
HARVARD DOES NOT MEAN HE IS WISE
OR EVEN SMART.
BUT WHEN YOU OPEN YOUR SEGMENT
ON ECONOMICS BY SAYING "I TALKED
TO A PUBLIC RADIO HOST WHO DOES
A SHOW WITH THE WORD ECONOMICS
AND THE TITLE AND HERE'S WHAT I
LEARNED" --
[LAUGHTER]
YOU ARE NOT TRYING VERY HARD,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HIS CONCLUSION
IS INFLATION IS A MEASURE OF OUR
SUCCESS?
BE GRATEFUL YOU CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD TO EAT MEAT, Y